do you think that you're an alcoholic no
I've been I've run it through the ringer
a few times Dr Drew's my litmus oh yeah
and I've talked to him about it he's
like you're not an alcoholic you just
drink too much he's like alcoholism is
different being powerless to alcohol is
different than drinking a lot I drank a
lot yesterday and I woke up in the
middle of the night in a [ __ ]
Sizzle I mean I was so hot and all of a
sudden my body went
and [ __ ] poured sweat back to sleep
yeah yeah like almost like when a truck
stops and it's like
it woke me up I was so hot I've never
done
I've never done the whole recovery thing
and uh did you ever think about it
because you go I mean you go pretty hard
you know I think about it all the time
yeah I mean the problem I have is uh
the problem I have is that what happens
is when I feel like I'm going too hard
there's this internal kind of uh
metronome in me that goes it's time to
slow down it's time to you gotta let's
let's do a couple nights off let's you
know
and not the way like a regular person
would go like we'll just drink on
weekends you know and I'll be like I'll
just I won't drink Monday Tuesday you
know Monday Tuesday Wednesday or like
it's gonna sound like this is gonna be
the most
horrific statement you'll ever hear me
sign a podcast trust me but like or or
you'll go let's let's not drink on
private jets you know like that's like
if you brought in a private jet to get
yourself to work maybe you should use
that as that really expensive plane
ticket as a time to uh recovery and and
work hard and read a script and not just
part of your [ __ ] dick off like I
have the whole time I've ever gotten
private I get on a private jet and I'd
be like if I'm paying 13 000 30 000
whatever I'm paying for a flight I'm
partying my [ __ ] dick off we're
eating Edibles we're [ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] get [ __ ] wasted oh
dude and then and then I started going
no I should probably not do that I
should probably use this as a time to
work on my business because it's a
business expense technically I drank
perfectly in Italy oh wow
perfectly I mean so here's my thing with
drinking if I if I Day drink it [ __ ] me
up I can't Day drink really so like I
can only drink I need to have that's why
the road works well for me because I
don't have my first drink till like
midnight oh wow yeah yeah so I'll drink
midnight till two whenever bus call is
maybe have a pop on the bus not lately
because I have acid reflux so usually
you just have a couple drinks you know
after the show two or three drinks and
then on the bus go to sleep maybe hit a
vape pen
let a joint go to bed and and I'm out
listen to a podcast I'm out and then
wake up the next day a little late but I
don't drink the whole [ __ ] day so
that's really good for me
because day drinking if I that's why I
don't drink on Jets or I drink on planes
because I if I Day drink on a plane then
it goes out throughout the day and then
that really puts a dent on your on your
on your Wellness like you just feel like
[ __ ] your sweat smells like piss you're
shaky your piss smells like sweat
no your sweat smells like piss too both
of them yeah both of them I mean when
you're in my balls smelled I drank all
day yesterday [ __ ] started it like
seven so you just did it yeah yesterday
but I but I busted my ass in the gym
today so it got out of me yeah but uh my
ball smelled the worst anyone's balls
have ever smelled in their entire life
when I got in the shower to come here I
took a little dab and sniff and I was
like
whoo that's worse than armpits oh that's
[ __ ] and that was that was booze so
how jealous do you think the front the
the how jealous do you think the back of
your balls are of the front of your
balls dude
well the back of your balls hang out
with your [ __ ] the front of your
balls hangs out with your dick yeah I'd
much rather hang out with a dick than an
[ __ ] me too imagine is being back
there it's like living in the slums it's
like
it's like a
you like to be alive I love being alive
it's like my favorite part of being
alive is loving that you're alive right
like if you just kind of go I'm alive
you know there's times you know there's
times where I'm I wake up and I'm rough
this is when we're talking about like
the recovery brain of like man what what
should I do and then I think the
difference is I wake up and if I feel a
little down a little depressed maybe a
little hungover maybe a little shaky
from partying too hard I go you have two
options today you can lose today you can
lose it you're allowed to you're allowed
to take a Xanax Tap Out get back in bed
crank up the AC throw on Netflix put it
on a Spanish-speaking cooking show and
just go to sleep for the whole day you
can do that or you can choose to win the
day where you get up you have a coffee
you Barrel through it you go to the gym
you work out and you just ignore that
voice in your head that goes hey man
we're not going to be able to do this
today you go I'm not listening to you
today I chose to seize today and and and
knowing for me knowing that I have that
tap out of like hey we can call it a day
we can wake up and call it a day make a
breakfast sandwich eat a Xanax watch
Netflix crank up the AC blackout
curtains sleep wake up at eight and have
a cocktail with your wife and have a
great [ __ ] day we can do that or we
can push through the day we can get up
early we can go have a coffee we have a
treat maybe a little bit of Instagram a
treat you know a little yeah and then
get in the gym push through it piss
sweat in the sauna in the polar plunge
and you will feel better you will feel I
promise you you will feel better and
what do you choose I always choose the
the one where I work out I always choose
it I've choose I've chosen
Xanax before I have right I have my wife
always knows it and she's like oh it's
so funny I thought you were different
than that but you just gotta you gotta
choose to not listen to that voice in
your head that's going we can't do this
man this is too hard I think that's
where some people struggle with like
alcoholism I think that void it's not
even sometimes about the drugs alcohol
it's just about that voice the next day
and how much it like haunts them or like
how much it like the drugs Now call fuel
whatever the negative feelings like it
just it's such a gasoline on those
thoughts and feelings do you ever feel
like do you ever feel like maybe and uh
by the way we don't have to keep this in
if you don't want to but do you ever
feel like I always wonder with you
because I know you're sober do you ever
feel like maybe there was just aspects
of your sobriety maybe there was aspects
of your partying they should never have
been included yeah like cocaine yeah
like that should never have been in your
mix right and you should have never been
introduced to it and had you never been
introduced to it you may be able to have
a few beers with people I'm not saying
by the way I'm not I'm not oh I want you
to I want your happiness now you want to
think about that every day do you ever
think that way oh yeah cocaine I can't
do it it [ __ ] me up so bad that I want
to quit everything yeah I go [ __ ] it
it's like the next day off of cocaine
I'm literally
um I'm literally waiting for the stroke
to hit I'm going like it's coming right
now it's coming right now why did I do
this why did I do this to myself yeah
it's like that no whammys like that game
show yeah no whammys no whammys it's a
heart attack God damn it my heart's
facing it's a dumbest dude yeah
cocaine's just insane man if I never
found cocaine yeah I never had any
problem with anything else is that crazy
so sometimes I think maybe at some point
I would just not do cocaine but yeah I
mean but it leads to it yeah that's the
problem is it's once you once you find
out you can once you find out you can
just turn around in the median and go
the other direction on the highway it's
really hard to not do that every time
yeah like if you never knew if you never
knew you couldn't do that yeah when
people were like yeah I I and then I
realized why I never even super enjoy
drinking because cocaine you like I can
get messed up right now
right now and marks get go you know what
I'm saying it really does it really is
so much better than a shot it's just
like it's like and that's the thing it's
like you don't want to fuel that voice
because in some people that voice is
already kind of like animated yeah and
so yeah sometimes people are drinking to
shut that voice off right and then and
when you sober up that voice goes he's
just hear him wake up like
what the [ __ ] did you you tried to kill
me without alcohol last night oh Welcome
to Hell [ __ ] let's check our net
we got genital warts
yeah dude I mean that voice that's why
Xanax is so great Xanax I never had no
Xanax oh Xanax just grabs him real quick
like a [ __ ] Gracie grabs his ghee and
goes like this good night good night you
go to my bed now and he's like crap
breathe
and then all of a sudden Xanax comes you
come out of his Xanax and you hear that
voice and he's like he's like how long
have I been out for
and you're like all right you're good
man just lay there for a little bit lay
there wake up and he's like okay
oh [ __ ] what day is that and you're like
it's Thursday and he's like no [ __ ] what
are we doing this weekend like don't
worry about we're gonna have a drink
later tonight let's just shut the [ __ ]
up and he's like
dude I got [ __ ] up last night what
happened it's like this is my whole
thing's shutting that voice down by the
way I'm sure there's someone who runs a
Recovery Center that right now that's
like oh Bernie's going to recovery
tomorrow
and by the way we need to can't get rid
of this podcast you've just got everyone
back on go game
I don't know that well these days also
cocaine got too dangerous to even do so
it's like funny now one of the things
that keeps me from doing cocaine is
cocaine because it's like it's not it
just there's no reliability with it like
I remember uh
uh trying to convince somebody like oh
this guy gets legit cocaine and like
where does he get it from and I'm like
ah you're right
look he drives a [ __ ] Dodge Neon okay
I'm sure it's good dude look at this
[ __ ] line in his hair come on
guys look at his fingernails they're
pedicures pedicures we're good I'll tell
you right now no one comments on your
drinking if you're skinny when you're
fat and I've been really fat I kind of
still am that's when you get people
showing up I had a week where I had
three people tell me they were worried
about me but they were just worried
about me because I would look like [ __ ]
and I was fat I was 265 pounds I told
someone I told someone the other day who
was I talking to I said I was 265 pounds
and he goes 270. I went no I was never
270 he goes yeah you were you just
didn't know it wow because once you
weigh yourself at 265 going I look good
today and then you're like 265 that's
[ __ ] fat well there's days you're
270. and so uh I think three people
reach out to me and go hey man I'm
worried about you I'm concerned for you
um one of them counted two of them
didn't
um that didn't count but right but
you're like how do you know I was like
if I've been around me you just saw me
one time and you were partying with me
and and and and by the way you're not my
wife you're not my best friend like if
Tommy says to me I'm worried about you
then I listen right but like
so yeah but uh and I lost my lost like
20 pounds and uh and then nobody said
anything no one said anything lately and
I probably partying just as hard as I
always have I just go like yeah man I'll
[ __ ] push it till the wheels come off
and they'll come off they'll come off
there'll be a time where I'm like I
don't know man I don't know maybe I'll
just die look I died in a plane crash
they never came off I just died I'll be
a [ __ ] Legend he died in a plane
crash yeah tour bus accident
not as much I think so I think that
plane crash people respect that 25 000
feet you went through yeah you know and
then wondering what he was doing the
whole time on the way down I'll tell you
what standing up drinking Jack Daniels
going [ __ ] it if it's your time to go
it's your time to go and I'm cranking up
Freebird Leonard Skynyrd
if I leave here tomorrow some people
would chime in dude and I'm hoping I'm
hoping that that coward buckled into the
back yeah tells that story man he went
down that's Ronnie Van Zant went down
like that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one